colombia está entre los países
seleccionados por el mecanismo kóvacs de
lado ms para hacer los primeros
beneficiados con 20 millones de dosis
contra el hobbit 19 esta nación que
registra más de 2 millones de
contagiados por coronavirus detectó
hasta este sábado el primer caso de
contagio por la cepa brasileña del virus
en la región amazónica tal y como lo
confirmó el ministerio de salud
colombiano de dicha variante aún se
conoce poco pero para los expertos bien
podría ser la más preocupante entre las
existentes
si tuviéramos que hacer una
clasificación la variante brasileña es
la más peligrosa seguida de la ciudad
africana y la inglesa en el sentido de
tener más mutaciones en esa región
crítica nutrición crítico ni siempre
imagen no siempre es peor aunque en el
caso del coronavirus puede serlo 5 curó
la uis a pesar de esto con
aglomeraciones y sin tapabocas los
fanáticos celebraron la conquista del
palmeiras de la copa libertadores en las
calles de sao paulo
[Aplausos]
este enero honduras registra las cifras
más altas de contagios y muertes desde
marzo tras la relajación decembrinas en
guatemala el gobierno anunció el arribo
de 800 mil vacunas en febrero a través
del sistema kóvacs bolivia sigue con el
proceso de vacunación del personal
médico con el primer lote de 20.000
dosis de la vacuna rusa sputnik bay que
llegó esta semana al país
yo creo que esperaría 9 no me va a
canarias en la en las primeras las
primeras tandas tal vez esperar un poco
más para ver las reacciones de las
personas igual de las demás vacunas tal
vez llegan igual otras vacunas de por
mediante empresas privadas algo así
esperaría la verdad y en perú cerca de
300 retratos de médicos fallecidos por
kobe 19 hacen parte de un memorial en
lima que empezó en junio de 2020 y desde
entonces no para de crecer